he's young ladies coming in they're
coming in right now
lottie's young latest quick break and
we're back because Andrea barber and
Jodie Sweetin are coming in so good
shall we so I'm so glad you did that
because it wasn't enough to say it yeah
from fuller house welcome have it late
how are you how are you doing how's the
morning been so good yeah okay so you
were on full house yeah we did a little
research on you you do you remember us
you were here before yes I do
well welcome back thank you has it been
like long enough now I would assume for
a while you guys didn't want to talk
about full house at all like you wanted
to kind of get done with it right after
it or not really no we've never had that
reaction like something that we hated
you know I mean like it was always
something that I mean we had a great
experience with it it was always
something we enjoyed so I don't think we
ever like tried to run away from me then
there a point like when you're an adult
like when you do something you're a kid
where you want like a let's talk about
the adult projects cuz they just keep
well yeah I mean you know it's always
nice to sort of move on and be able to
talk about other things but it's never
anything that we're like we're not
talking about this you know trust me
there's certain child stars that have
you know in their contract that you
can't mention certain things do they
real really yeah what can't you mention
I'm not gonna say cuz then you know who
I'm talking about but they don't like to
be reference oh yeah but it's so fun
like the more people wait Thank You
Holland Vicki you can't mention the
project in an interview or on set I'd
like on set like if they're doing
something new they don't want it to be
met yet so like in the person like you
can't just like I know isn't that weird
like I mean you know all right like I
said at the end of the day like nobody
would have given a [ __ ] about any of us
had we not been on fallout which is the
healthiest attitude to have it's like
very grateful yeah yeah because it cuz
the more you tried it like the people
who really try to fight and don't bring
that up and don't talk about it it's
like those are the people who would
holds them back right like the ones that
just kind of embrace it and then keep
moving right
really never hurts exact well you know
it's we all have have you know those
projects that were like you know what
this is this is what we're known for him
we have fun with it and yeah we get to
do other stuff as adults but an open the
door yeah I would love to know what we
said you can't say to this other person
if you even in conda's conversation shut
down it's interesting because I'm sure
other people have that stuff like you
can't say hey I enjoyed your work and
out of the program no it's like yeah
like certain catch for it like they're
like you can't make rap dino lies ya
can't do that one right yeah yeah but I
mean stuff like that where people with
tragic raises just drop stuff like off
the craft services table and go can I do
that
what's that one I don't know an Urkel
that's kind of a big one now I was an
adult by that and watch the family uh
what's called a family matter yeah I
don't lie okay
I was busy can't call Michael J Fox Alex
P Keaton I don't think he'd care no I
don't think so he's a good egg I don't
think he would care okay so it's a
catchphrase thing I know dynomite Jimmie
Walker you gotta pay him extra to say
that really high stage yeah cuz he's
just tired of it and when you been
saying that same dumb word since 1962 or
not you should start charging for how
rude George how rude is gonna be like on
my tunes how do you get started like i
how rude like i've just settled into it
like whatever that'll be $500 right yes
yeah she's my agent I have to tell you
as somebody who grew up with the show
that was exciting when you said that
just now oh so I gather
I got where that comes in yeah it's you
know I get it I mean those childhood
shows how many times have you said that
in real life like that so many writing
immediate if I heard your husband how
rude don't bring the show [ __ ] you yeah
but you probably yeah that's probably
one of those things you have to leave on
everybody's voicemails
uh-huh is you and stuff hey you've
reached Sam but I'm not here right now
wait do you think how rude no no no
please Michelle record that's recorded
alright okay just I should just start
saying it like completely the opposite
of how I said it on now and nobody asked
me why rude oh yeah yeah I was a rocking
I just
strange like yeah when you and Ryu left
acting all together after the show right
I did I left this the show and went to
college right but when you're in college
like like I would imagine everybody's
coming up to you cuz they would have all
grown up with the show too so that
becomes a thing doesn't it like this is
the kimijima Kimmy Gibbler goes to this
school do you know that this quality I
go dude he was probably talked about a
lot like behind closed doors because I
didn't hear I didn't hear much of it it
was talking about more in high school
when I'm because I went to a regular
public high school when I was in house
and so it was more people were like
teasing yeah can you get Larry I know
your feet stink and it's like shut up
right um but in college no people are
cool they're cool they're mature they're
just experienced I'm moving into the
dorms and they like played the full
house themes why'd you leave acting I'm
Lida who's who's leaving acting going to
college this somebody is just talking
about yeah we were just talking about
that the other day somebody who's got a
great career and they're thinking about
oh yeah coral for blocking down from
walking yeah yeah we were taking on he's
leaving the show that's maybe he might
just be use enough to negotiate more
money oh but wait when you would you
decide to leave acting is are you really
sick of it or did you audition and
nothing else was happening yeah let me
just go to college and what made you
want to do no I just I had a great
experience on Full House and I thought
this was a great hobby as a child like
you know some kids play sports and for
me I was on a hit TV show and I was just
ready to learn new things you weren't
you were driven to continue it no wow no
I just didn't desire yet cuz for those
of us on the outside we're like this
sort of like oh I just want to be a
normal kid like why like no being a
normal kid is the worst you're on a TV
show GT being on more divisional kids
sucks worse it's not fun no
did you kept acting after it I did I
acted for a little while but I also you
know I went to UM I was a lot younger
when the show finished I was just
starting high school so I but I went to
performing arts high school I did
musical theater for four years and then
I went to college to Performing Arts
High School where LA OH
in Orange County oh okay some people
annoyed at your high school when you
started auditioning for the plays cuz
it's like of course they're gonna put
Stephanie in the play like no you know
we had
I mean we had a lot of really talented
people I went to school with Taryn
Manning who's on orange America Matt
Morrison who did Glee yeah a lot of
theater stuff yeah there were a lot of
people at you know at that school that
that went on to do some really great
things who were also super talented so
it wasn't you know I definitely I was
not like the only talented person at
that school was actually really stiff
competitions but were you annoyed that
you had to audition like that's gotta
suck you really went there like all
right everybody's auditioning you're an
audition how rude you know oh my god
you're snapchatting how rude this is so
much fun I don't man yeah snap Fanny and
make analogies to shows that is dirty
when they came out excuse me excuse me
Bob Saget snapchats more than anybody is
including teenagers yeah so you know who
knows if there's an age limit on
snapchat are they doing cameos because
the second season of fuller house is on
Netflix right now
yes um are there because the first
season of course you got to do the
cameos right B and then it sets up for
the fact that it's a different show yeah
are there still are they doing cameos
again this season yeah yeah they still I
think each of them did like three
episodes um well this season is all
about the holidays it's you know
Halloween and Thanksgiving and Christmas
so of course the whole family comes back
for a lot of the holidays so that's so
funny began because you they're like
that's like a sitcom staple right like
the holiday episode all this is the
likeliness holiday we're gonna smash
them all into one season right and it
makes sense and then really fine wise
Christmas everyone's super excited to
watch it so yeah it's really it's got to
be very hard to uh when you have
something big to walk away from it and
then come back to it's gonna be great to
come back to it like you still hold out
hope for all these years like maybe
we'll do something else and then it kind
of doesn't that fade after a while um
yeah I mean I don't know I think we all
you know we always have remained in
contact but I don't think that any of us
ever expected to necessarily come back
and redo you know the Tanners and
pretty mind-blowing yeah and now we need
to do it and people are really loving it
as sort of a standalone show and its own
thing so it's I mean it's exciting you
know I saw pictures you guys are in
Japan so yes I was amazed that they
should like a whole bunch of fans like
is a huge all over the world it's not
just Japan loves full house and now
fuller house like it's crazy yeah I mean
we air in all 64 countries at Netflix is
on and it's very popular and all like
all over the world they send you all of
these the place to promote Janice went
to Berlin and then we just went to Japan
and I know some of our cast went to
Argentina yeah so we get to go all over
the world I guess it's like the
all-american family right and so like
any country that's got any sort of
reverence for American culture with
Japan it's like obsessed with alright
yeah it's gonna go crazy for the show
yeah that's pretty amazing I didn't I
didn't make that connection but maybe
that's what it is they do love America
yeah they love American culture and and
our show has been on there for quite a
number of years you talk shows when
you're over there
uh what do you do with that press we did
we did a lot of um like magazine press
um but I did I did a talk show like live
streaming talk show with Japan when I
was in LA that we did that was like a
satellite thing that was you know live
with all Japanese and I have like a
translator in my ear it's very hard that
you're like super distracted because
they're talking you're trying to listen
that's crazy
when they send you over there it's more
for the photo-op because they could
easily send a reporter here to talk to
you and get all they do they send a lot
of Japanese press to the set but they
yeah they'd wanted us to go over there
and just to be around all the Japanese
fans it's a great photo op we did it a
mere event where they recreated the
living room set on the stage and we all
walked out and there were about 200 300
fans in the audience and all their
cameras and all the press in the front
it was it was so cool today
Indiana living room hip tag Indian press
there we did Filipino press we did a
couple other like Asian countries as
well came to do press but by the way if
I say photo-op again throw coffee in my
face eight times the photo-op
I don't use that we argue that's your
our way
was as was doing the show like the
reboot was it a no-brainer for both of
you or were you guys waiting to see who
else signed up or what the scripts look
like or or what were your experiences I
citing instant yeah well what Jeff
Franklin called me and said would you be
interested in doing something like this
it was an instant yes but it took a few
years to get but even for you wasn't
really acting well it's just it's going
back and doing what I did for eight
years right you know you're a different
person now see how you acted it all in
between those No Oh user nothing Sophia
but as an adult you're doing something
you did when you were younger now you
know about like as an adult you
understand the concepts of failing or
being afraid whereas when you're a kid
it's just easier so I think it's pretty
amazing it's when walk back into it
especially because you wanted like two
stars to the show like it's kind of sent
you're not just the neighbor anymore
right you know well and I it's all I
came back mostly because it was such a
great experience as a kid and because I
wanted to work with Jodie Sweetin again
is and we had such we were so so close
as a cast back then and we remained so
close in that interim and I figured it
was probably gonna be a pretty great
experience again why do you suppose
there's no disasters to come from that
show there's a lot of kids involved in
full house and I I don't really think
that there have been we've all managed
it you know we've we've all had life
happened but we all managed to kind of
you know make it out through the other
end so it's you know we to be honest we
we all had great families outside of the
show and we had a great family
connection on the show so I think you
know we've had the support of a lot of
people are did you guys learn for like
the different strokes cast like this
some of them that really did
self-destruct him either all of them the
whole cast
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know also I
think are the producers on our show were
incredibly mindful and conscious of like
letting us have as many normal kid
experiences as possible and making sure
that we had you know kind of one foot in
real life you know and I mean I remember
sending you off to prom and you know
like they would have those moments where
it was like look these are important
milestones for you guys and we want to
make sure that you don't miss out on
them oh nice did you have I did one
project that had a kid on it for a bunch
of episodes it was like it was weird how
they would have like she'd have to go
off into school like they had a tutor
for but I mean they made sure that she
was not just on the set the whole time
well you
legally you have to do at least three
hours of school a day and yeah like
that's child labor laws and all that
kind of stuff yeah well I do I have two
daughters uh eight and six you want them
to be in acting if that's what they
really want to do but I think that right
now they're happy in school although our
daughters actually did an episode of the
show this this year they were extras on
the show I'm very excited about it did
you guys have stage mothers like you
know like like who is it because you
went into it so young you have to have a
parent pushing you into it right or not
push you but you know we were parents
that we're very supportive of us but it
was net they never pushed it on yeah but
they were supportive of what we wanted
to do yet that's where it always gets
into trouble when like the kid becomes
the breadwinner for the household yeah
it's like no we got to still be like if
you're ever not having fun with us and
you don't want to do it anymore
stop yeah yeah and I'd like my parents
were super normal and and never like
when I was three or four I was like I
really want to act in loans like all
right start doing commercials and then
it just sort of snowball but she like
they always told me if you don't if
you're not having fun and you don't want
to do this anymore like we will not make
you do this you want to make them when
you're the kid making money it's a good
it's kind of a hobby I still work my my
my dad still wish my mom had a job like
it wasn't you know I wasn't the
breadwinner that what do they do
my mom she was a little bit later on in
the show like she started managing other
kids and she started a an event planning
business and then my dad was a
superintendent at a gypsum plant in Long
Beach harbor blue collar yeah for real
it's a job what's the gypsum plant up
drywall oh yeah and then he had a
business as a handyman for a long time
like the regular job yeah regular job I
came from very very normal people I'm
not a very handy person you're not in a
three oh don't say that shocked like you
are yeah I like fix things around the
house all the time
I don't know a handyman or not I had a
very noisy teaming your parents my
parents were very very knit well yes
why'd you amend that you were gonna say
Carol II know my parents are very nerve
there great I love him my dad was a
lawyer in my my mom was a stay-at-home
mom so they're normal but they're my
parents and so you know they they could
but aggravate you sorry are all three of
our moms myself kanna-san and ander
our moms and dads still come to every
taping the show and are just super
excited to see us getting to do what we
love they're really supportive it's like
a reunion for the play our parent on the
show I'm Candace Cameron Bure as parents
she didn't come in she's not doing
presses cuz she left with you she don't
want to you want to talk no no she's on
of you right now she is she hasn't have
an end date yet oh yeah because I was
about to ask you guys I'd be pissed if
she was on the show with me and she left
the view now cuz I'd be like there's a
lot of promo and fall today so you know
they oppressed yesterday okay good good
good oh that's my feelings are hurt we
shouldn't just cancel this show she
she's not what yeah she's not doing any
stuff with us today just because she
still had to do the view oh her breast
day with us was yesterday oh okay that
makes sure it's rolling nothing personal
not rolling it's like something that guy
I'm so not doing yeah so when you
started dating how did you know guys
weren't just dating you like because of
you were on the show like isn't that
awkward like you don't know if the guy
is just a big family yeah you can kind
of tell you can't have a sixth sense I
think growing up because car you Kimmy
by mistake maybe our history house house
shaped DVD box don't worry about how is
that how they would be they're having a
house shaped box are they coming out
yeah I guess mark you yeah you pick up
on that great quick the same thing with
friendships you can kind of tell which
friends are genuine friends and who just
wants to get to know you just to kind of
run what's what's the giveaway um
what they want to talk about is I asked
a lot about questions about John Stamos
it's like alright let's move on to a
different topic hey you want to hang out
with a bunch of my friends tonight yeah
like what like Dave Coulier and stuff
yeah yeah you should just lie in record
for the most John Stamos like [ __ ] his
pants a lot yes that's what he wanted oh
yeah no no he wasn't sick or anything
she's really lazy just give them
terrible let's give it yeah exactly were
you worried at all when you put your
book out and you kind of talked about
your past and everything that it would
spoil the image of you is like this
innocent kid that people had in their
heads too much that you couldn't go back
to it no I mean you know it's a piece of
who I am it's not who I am anymore
right so it's you know now
to move on and do other stuff what was
in the book that would what was it did
you get drug drugs drugs how old why
sound a lot of stuff that I don't need
to talk about anymore oh yeah yeah
there's a whole lot
it was a great autobiography and it was
a great way for Jodie to share her story
and I'm probably very cathartic to and
I'm proud of her and get it out right
yeah do you regret it or no the book
well yeah yeah we're like now I have to
go back to this show where I'm you know
that's not a part of my image yet I mean
no it's just you know I get to move on
and do new stuff I don't you know I
don't really think about it anymore just
as someone who has discussed things that
I probably shouldn't have you feel like
that yet Jim Dorn is what we call Google
a bull yeah yeah yeah
made a lot of mistakes we all do yeah
yeah yeah
we all make mistakes like it's part of
it exactly yeah part of it and you get
to learn and move on all right what do
you do you get weirded out at all when
you find out because the the new show
fuller house which as we said it's on
Netflix season 2 its first of all the
first season was like super successful
right didn't efflux say it was one of
like their top original Netflix didn't
say but outside sources said
alright slicks won't tell they never
tell you numbers I never know which has
its pluses and minuses it's kind of nice
because in a way you're not beholden to
you know numbers and ratings and all
that kind of stuff you just know that if
people are watching it for whatever
niche audience it fills the Netflix is
happy I think they also don't want you
to be on negotiate yeah that's that's
not because they don't tell us numbers
it's serious either and we know what's
going on they just say you're bombing
well you know if you keep coming back
like alright well I still have a job
yeah yeah that's what they want like
look it's good enough that we're gonna
do a sounds like okay I think we all had
a pretty good idea that the show was
immensely popular yeah yeah and it's
interesting that like older people are
watching it even though it's like this
clear thing that like full house was
designed for kids and families and I
think fuller house is the same way but a
lot of older people that don't have kids
or families they just watch the show
growing up or just yeah I'm changing
this show people look you know they're
they love the show and we moved
tried to you know put a little bit of a
modern edge on and it's not quite as
saccharine as it was in the 80s you know
but it's still a family television show
and and but we have fun with that and we
try to kind of you know acknowledge that
and be a little bit self aware of it
what do you know is there any shot that
the Olsen twins will because it when you
look at the Wikipedia about it it's like
they're questionable I guess they don't
want to totally write them off as we I
mean we've always said you know the
doors always open to them and they left
back to you too went you know yeah when
they were they making more money now
though with this like fashion empire
they have but they're doing fine a lot
of cake yeah yeah we are em they're
gonna be just fine if they ever want to
come back the doors always open but if
they don't we have a great show right
yeah I don't think I don't think people
watch it and go oh you know what we
really just the only thing that we need
it I think people enjoy it
why have you forgot they were on until I
just ask you that it's a I really did
it's got to be annoying when you're
doing a show that's very successful to
have people going what about them like
yeah we got to show it out there but you
just asks that's kind of the point I'm
making like right I just probably did
that thing that gets annoying but I just
I you know I forgot they were ever on
the show yeah I mean that's you know I
got a question a lot the first season
yeah that was the number one question we
got doing season 1 but with season 2
it's been just a couple of questions
here and there so I think people are
realizing that this is a great show no
matter who shows up Jim was just really
asking an annoying question because he
was hoping he get the catchphrase again
he would tell him it was right I've
reached my daily yeah we're with you I
can only say it so many times a day we
really screwed it for any other show
you're doing yeah we really we took them
all for sure man yeah I would hate the
date so what about a catchphrase
would you yes why why she probably use
it a lot yeah what I do I get my exes of
all had catchphrases well like what kind
of catchphrases of your exes head how
come about things not hard
that's right the reaction to catch fish
yes done man
she hasn't done that in other instances
it's important to everybody of catch
phrases though I apologize I wonder if
if the networks are kind of realizing
because it seems like Netflix is kind of
tapped into something that a lot of the
network's figured like I know I don't
know about that on or just because they
haven't tried this stuff like your show
and other shows that Netflix is done
narcos the next ethics is great yeah
they've been are really successful
they're doing something like HBO did was
all the brilliant original program and
now Netflix is doing it yeah yeah yeah I
mean I think you know the reports were
that ABC's viewing actually went down
what like a significant percentage when
season one the night that season one
premiered really yeah so people are
literally the audience that would that
that watched our show and so you know I
think they were kind of kicking
themselves in the ass but maybe see
first talking about doing this but we
went pitched it to them and yeah and so
you know and they were like well we
don't know if isn't we're like okay
that's like you know The Sopranos was
pitched to Fox yeah and they said they
said no you know what wouldn't you have
anything great there's certain things
you have to do on on the premium network
yeah you know and I think that um I
think Netflix has actually been a great
home for us because you know our fans
love to binge watch the show they love
to watch it over and over and over again
they've watched the same hundred ninety
two episodes for almost 30 years really
so you know they love the opportunity
that they can just watch this over and
over and over and over again and like
watch it all at once
yeah it's but it is funny like a show
like that which could be done on
televisions it's not yet not goes you
probably got to do where you do it
what's interested in Netflix is really
smart about not just going for shows
that like well of course that's on
Netflix like I know they're actually
picking up like they picked up Chelsea
show so now they're tapping into those
people who watch late-night TV and
they're realizing that the people who
still do watch network sitcoms right
that is an audience and we can get them
over anywhere you know one of the big
things that they were looking for when
we went and pitched them the show was
like family cove Ewing opportunities
where
parents and families and kids would all
sit down and watch a show together
because that doesn't that didn't really
exist for a long time there was like you
know your kids cartoon shows or there
was narcos and house of cards and things
like that
there wasn't a lot that families could
watch together and families still want
to watch TV together like I would still
want to sit down and watch something
with my kids that like you know isn't
gonna be totally offensive although my
kids watch Family Guy and it goes
totally over their head how old is your
oldest again eight okay Jim just said
that at nine that's the time when when
kids should realize that Santa is not
really before that well for me I think
she's she's holding on to the last straw
I think she started being like really
but you know she's got a little sister
and I'm like if you blow this for her I
was seven when I found out but I mean I
find it for my friends and my mother
yeah I mean if she asked you know I'll
always be honest with them but she still
has that little I think glimmer and hope
of magic and I want to ruin it yeah you
don't want to wreck it I mean how about
your your kids you've kids I have to
have 12 year old and a 9 year old and my
my 12 year old boy he's kind of figured
it out right around 9 but my 9 year old
girl still holds on but I think she just
wants more present that's what I did on
that [ __ ] for like two years and I was
like this is so not real but I get
double right no it's [ __ ] but you're
like oh my god but and there's party
it's like oh but it is magical and fun
and you know like I look forward to the
holidays and like having that moment
where they wake up on you 17 thinking Oh
mom this common thing is that when
you're a kid you can ask for more stuff
with Santa because you're not saying mom
could you get me right there like Santa
and the elves are building it right
right the elves are built yeah you know
all there's all kinds of stuff and you
yeah and then if you don't get it then
you get you all to criticize your
parents you wet Santa's real piece of
garbage and your parents can say yeah
Santa sucks
well the the second season of fuller
house is now available on now it's on
Netflix you can binge it all weekend you
can how many episodes is it 13 13 13
brand new episodes so congratulations on
getting the second season thank you very
much in this whole this whole journey
has been pretty amazing yeah it hasn't
it continues to be so here's here's to
many more yes thank you
absolutely.i Barbour and Jodie Sweetin